[Music]
you ever gonna ask me out we'll just
waiting for the right moment I'll see
you around
Abbie I'm waiting for the right moment
because when I ask you out there's not
gonna be any turning back for me I'm not
gonna date anybody else for the rest of
my life I'm not gonna love anybody else
for the rest of my life I'm waiting for
the right moment cuz when I asked you
out it's gonna be the most important
moment of my life and I just want to
make sure that I get it right life is
not tricks us it misleads us it paints
one man a hero when he may well be a
villain hero or villain what villain or
hero that I was in my maybe the heroes
and villains of our stories are actually
just day players and a much bigger movie
but uh
was naked dreams and I want to live a
big great fantastical life let's get
married
we've been dating less than a year I
know I feel like I've shown incredible
restraint waiting this long you may
[Music]
I love you I may not be equipped to be
loved this much
gonna take this the wrong way I'll ever
love it wasn't for will to marry a woman
of a dead parents old enough to share
the grandchildren and mom it's okay she
knows
[Music]
[Music]
so strange how completely random moment
that happened way before I was born but
shaped my entire life
are you glad it happened start small
grow tall hey are you pregnant
dosmo Rotom
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you